Mitt Romney is blasting Marjorie Taylor
green on her secession Insanity we're
going to look at a short clip remember
that Marjorie Taylor green last week
said that we need a national divorce
where we divide up into red States and
blue States I told you all of the
reasons why that makes no sense uh
Senator Mitt Romney a republican was
asked about it and here's what he had to
say senator what do you think about
Marjorie Taylor Green's call on social
media media for a national
trip between Republican and Democratic
states you know I think Abraham Lincoln
dealt with that kind of uh Insanity
we're not going to divide the country
it's a united we stand divided we fall
yeah listen I didn't vote for Mitt
Romney but he does seem like a
fundamentally decent and honest guy who
just tells you what he thinks and he
thinks a lot of Modern Republicanism is
completely insane now I've told you the
two main reasons why this entire
separate into two countries won't work
the first is the unconstitutionality of
unilateral secession now baby maybe
Marjorie Taylor green is talking about a
version where like everybody agrees
everybody's like no yeah yeah like
Oklahoma you should go go do your own
thing but the Constitution of the United
States which is the supreme law of the
land doesn't provide a provision for
secession and in fact the idea of
secession arguably was tested in the
Civil War
Supreme Court has ruled you can't just
secede States can't just say we succeed
it's not a legal option for any state if
you attempt to do it you would be
violating the Constitution and Supreme
Court rulings now the second part of it
is that the red States aren't viable as
a country and I know that if you watched
last week's show you already know this
but I do want to get it into this clip
as well the red State country that would
be created is fundamentally not viable
economically and this is for a number of
different reasons GDP per capita is much
lower in red States than blue states red
states are disproportionately subsidized
with Federal funding that comes from
Blue states which overwhelmingly pay
money in rather than get money out blue
States on average have more diverse
economies whereas red states often
depend on one industry or product or
sector
so it's very at risk to that one you
know oil in Texas or agriculture in
Kansas so that makes the economies
generally more vulnerable to economic
fluctuations there are on average more
educated people in the blue states that
leads to higher paying jobs and more
Innovation there's better infrastructure
as a result in the blue States
education and access to health care tend
to be better which also makes it more
attractive for business it's a vicious
cycle and right now to a great degree
the red states are being pulled up by
all of these aspects of blue States if
you've just got red States as a country
it really wouldn't work well at all and
Mitt Romney just pointing out that it
makes no sense for a number of reasons
good for Mitt Romney
I wish there were more Republicans
willing to stand up and just say these
these people shouldn't be here Marjorie
Taylor green is a disaster Mitt Romney
went up to George Santos George Anthony
devalder Santos during the state of the
union and said I'm shocked you're even
here
you should be ashamed
um if we had more Republicans like Mitt
Romney the Republican Party would be
just a party with we disagree with on
policy and less of the scourge or
scourge
on the United States that it has become